all right hi everyone so my name is Xiao
Incheon and with me it's not so we're
lucky and we're really excited to be
here today to talk about migrating and
modernizing your enterprise workloads
with my great Francis so I think my
great friend throws is a really unique
tool on the market and it can transform
your entire modernization strategy but
I'm getting ahead of myself
so before we talk about the what let's
first talk about why why do you want to
modernize your workload and why do you
want to run them on GKN anthos so there
are a lot of reasons why you might want
to run your workloads on GK and athos
first GKN and those are built upon
kubernetes so you've heard a lot about
kubernetes today a lot of our customers
who use kubernetes are telling us that
they're seeing a 10x improvement in the
speed with which they can deploy and
provision their workloads in addition
our customers are seeing much higher
utilization leading to large
double-digits infrastructure savings and
gke built upon this and provides an
easy-to-use simplified management
experience with features such as node
auto repair auto upgrade and auto scale
out and anthos takes that even further
and provides an application
modernization modernization platform
with a single pane of glass for managing
all of your workloads whether they're on
prem on tcp or on other clouds and of
course when you run your workloads on
TCP country K&N tha's you get access to
the best of GCP security with features
such as binary authorization and
container analysis and so all of these
benefits
taken together gives our customers the
ability to move faster be more agile and
be more competitive in the marketplace
and so we see a lot of customers want to
modernize but it's not easy and large
enterprises have a lot
unique challenges we have a lot of
customers that have hundreds of
applications in many cases they have
thousands of applications they were
written over the last 10-15 years using
legacy frameworks running on legacy
operating systems so what do you do with
these it's not really practical to
rewrite all of them make them more cloud
native use a microservices architecture
so what do you do now the good news here
is you don't actually have to rewrite
all of them we see modernization not as
a binary problem it's not all or nothing
and in fact even though your application
is not using a microservices
architecture you can still convert them
to using containers and get a lot of the
same benefits so this is where my gran
thoughts comes in so maybe for anthos is
a tool that helps you extract your
legacy workloads from your VMs and
automatically containerize them and run
them on gke the tool is fast it's easy
to use and it does not require rewriting
your app and that's a really key key
point and so when you're done you have
your work workloads running in
containers and you can leave the
management of the infrastructure of the
underlying infrastructure to us in fact
this reminds me of a conversation I had
with a partner recently who was really
excited about these features he told me
that via management is actually quite
error-prone and a big burden for IT so
if you are manually patching manually
upgrading these VMs then after a few
months or doing this over your fleet of
VMs you'll often see a few VMs that have
errors that run into errors and what
that means is it also affects the
applications that are running on top of
it and so after he learned about
kubernetes or learned about containers
he never wanted to go back to VM
management ever again and so VM
management is the elimination of OS of
VM management is of course only one of
the many benefits a customer of ours
I recently used migrant those and they
share their experience with us so
previously deaf factory was using they
had a lot of vm's and servers running in
a datacenter and they were seeing less
than 1% utilization so these VMs are
running there they're costing money but
they're not really being fully used so
deaf factory decided to use my great
friend OHS to move those workloads to GK
and immediately they were able to
achieve much higher resource utilization
leading to dramatically reduce costs and
also they can leave the management of
the infrastructure to us so they can
reduce their IT burden the overall
solution help them optimize their
operations so that they can focus on
their core business well ok so let's now
dive a little bit deeper into the
solution and see how it works at a high
level there are three main steps the
first step is to identify good fit
workloads so we'll talk about what good
fit means in a couple of slides your
source VMs can be on Prem on GCP on
other clouds and it can be on physical
servers the operating system can be any
one of the major Linux distributions the
next step is to migrate using my gran
throws the entire migration can be
orchestrated directly from gke
will automatically containerize your VM
workloads and will move all of your your
entire workload including your code your
data in your state
so everything moves over to a container
and finally the last step is to operate
and optimize so here you want to make
sure that you've set up your networking
rules or firewall rules access control
quote alerting and so on and then you
can enjoy the benefits of a managed
infrastructure including increased
utilization and elimination of OS
management's integrated logging
monitoring and of course the entire
stock is supported managed by Google
let's out dive into that second step
down migrate step
little bit more to see how we're
transforming your workload so if you
take a original VM there are a lot of
things that are inside there you have
your application it has attached storage
you're doing your own networking inside
there you have your DHCP configuration
for example you have operating system
services like SSH dntp D and so on
the VM is managing the lifecycle of your
application it does its own logging and
you have your own OS kernel drivers all
within that VM so when we perform that
transformation we turn that we put that
into a what we call a system container
and you can see at this points a lot of
the components in your original VM have
now been replaced and are now managed by
kubernetes so your storage is now
provided by persistent volumes within
kubernetes networking is now also
managed by kubernetes so you don't need
your own DHCP configuration and it can
seamlessly integrate with services like
sto operating system services like sshd
some of those stay and some of those get
removed and that is configurable by the
user
the application lifecycle stays within
the system container as far as logging
that's now integrated with kubernetes in
the cluster and so depending on your
cluster configuration you can have all
of your logs be sent directly to staff
driver and finally your operating system
kernel drivers those are no longer
managed within your workload so this is
what we do today now on a road map
moving forward we have plans to break
this up even further so we will split
your system container into one or more
application containers where each
container can now be each application
and container can now be managed
independently and directly by kubernetes
so the lifecycle management of that out
container will be managed directly by
kubernetes kubernetes will be able to
independently scale the app up and down
and apparently manage the whole the
health monitoring for that app and so on
and so as you can see as we go through
the phases
more and more of the infrastructure bits
that was inside your VM are now taken
out unbundled from your workload and can
be managed independently and centrally
within the infrastructure within
kubernetes okay
so zooming back out a question that we
get a lot from our customers is what is
a good fit workload what our sweet spot
workloads so our solution is actually
very generic and so we work very well it
works very well for a lot of workloads
so carbon workloads with an enterprise
like multi multi stack lamps Multi multi
tier lab stacks or Java apps those are
really good fits if you have low low low
duty cycle and bursty workloads those
also work really well because once you
put them into a container then it's easy
to over subscribe them and you can very
quickly scale up and scale down so
what's not a good candidate workload all
right so you want to make sure that the
workload will run well within kubernetes
and so that means if you have high
performance or high memory databases
that may not be a good fit if you have a
special kernel or hardware needs like if
you need a special kernel module that
also may not run with it in kubernetes
and finally you want to make sure that
you your licenses for software licenses
allow you to run within containers so if
you have licenses that are tied to a
hardware ID registration that also may
not be a good fit and in some of these
cases you may instead want to use
migrate for compute engine to move your
VM from your original cloud original
source data center into GCP okay so
another common question we get from
customers is once i've migrated my vm my
workload into the cloud how do i make
sure that it's well connected how do i
make sure it's connected to my services
that I need from I'm Prem how do I make
sure I'm Prem can talk to it and and
also what if I have some workloads that
I can't yet migrate to the cloud so how
do I make sure that those are you know
everything can still talk to me
so to tell us more about that I'd like
to turn it over to Matt thank you thank
you so what I'm sort of talk about is
sort of a couple of sort of customer
examples where they've had these
monolithic applications and in these
cases actually sort of before and those
Margaret Francis came along so I would
have saved him a fair bit of effort but
they've got there's more or less they
start on pram or even in the cloud but
we'll stay on creme and they want to
bring them across and they want to start
modernizing these applications they want
to break them down they want to actually
help them scale right but that's
actually really hard it's hard to start
breaking these things up and you want to
do it in a really really low risk way
right these are running no it's your
e-commerce platform with billing
integrated it's quite integrated with
the web sort of front-end all integrated
just ripping them out ad hoc and
rebuilding them is not normally sort of
something that people want to do because
it's still quarter their business so you
know we look at first ten euros in the
application I think that's probably one
of the most important first steps that
he's obviously a big challenge for some
legacy applications but we have stuff
like obviously migrate that helps make
that easier for Linux apps and then the
next part is like building a network
foundation so you want a foundation
where you can start to break this out
apart comfortably route traffic and
users to the broken out sort of services
and still make sure that the the stuff
in the monolith can still talk to those
broken out services that traffic can
still go to that monolith when it's
still handling certain tasks in a way
again that is like as low risk as
possible and that make sure you've
additionally rollback or you know sort
of manage around those changes trace
those changes deep bug those kind of
issues and then once you have that
foundation you can start sort of
breaking it down into micro services
much more comfortably so it's a bit of
sort of an overview of the major
components we've got containers
themselves we have a service mesh which
means a lot of different things to all
different people but the idea is
basically mere to have your services
talk to each other in a controlled and
debuggable way and service so that's you
know the idea that you're not running
sort of ops at AVM level or even many
ways a container level is you're dissing
look I want ten of these I want to scale
from zero to fifty and you know when we
have sort of fits into a whole toolkit
so you can see we have sort of migrate
for anthos on the Left we have you know
kubernetes itself we have GK ajk on pram
you have the spectrum of what we sort of
sort of think as the anthos service mesh
so envoy proxies so if you've ever used
sort of nginx before envoy suit of a
super-powered nginx we have sort of
dynamic configuration you can sort of
put in as a sidecar
or as a sort of a front proxy for
applications and do sort of traffic
shaping sto as a control plane and lot
of things in sto so certificate
management acting as a control plane for
your Envoy proxies by the Envoy api's
traffic director which is our version of
the control plane there's a managed
service since we know that managing
control planes can be pretty hard lie
seven load balancer sort of internal
load balancer for managing traffic
between services built on envoy G OPC is
communication mechanism and cloud run
which sort of goes back to the civil
spider I just mentioned before so these
are all the components and it's like
okay great I don't put all these
together how do I actually even know
where to start right I'm not going to
boil the ocean and just do all of this
at once that just doesn't make a lot of
sense so again we want to contain your
eyes first and then we want to sort of
start to mesh applications and build at
the service finishes that have it early
and very slowly so we can make major
changes as we go along so sort of
classic monolithic gap you know it's a
big probably existing Java code base
lots of different modules probably
deploy it maybe once maybe like three or
four times a year if you're really lucky
but you know you won't actually be able
to sort of break this down you want
teams to be able to be independent of
each other to also avoid team a from
blowing up the application of team B so
having canary sort of controls and
things like that as well being a
rollback and that sits on pram and you
just come in directly or maybe fly some
sort of DNS sort of traffic management
system if you've got a couple of data
centers so very sort of simple straight
forwards that have set up with a lot of
complexity underneath and what we still
want to think about is like great okay
let's stop plugging
in these pieces so I have Google's
Network in front of my application right
that's putting up our sort of global
load balancer with any cars with DDoS
protection we set of traffic routing
setting up an API gateway so this is
like the core foundation where you know
today there might be a really simple
case of just forward everything to the
monolith but as you start thinking
you're great
actually now I can start sort of carving
up very easily very carefully you know
my card my payment system my sort of
billing back-end you know with this
gateway ready so that when I start to
break out this model at the break down
its monolith I have those controls there
and again I'm gonna say this a lot you
can roll back carefully and measure
those changes really carefully and
obviously what you start to do is you
start to build that out and get your
cluster already on same gke which is
gonna be your foundation for sudden to
break these applications down so you
start to get some experience in GK you
start to understand how it sort of
abstracts virtual machines and sort of
how it manages the network itself as
well so we're breaking out one service
working at say sub-site that might be
our billing service or maybe a cart
service you know at API gateway sort of
that process is hey we're just gonna
send a small fraction of traffic over to
that at a time and then as we're happy
with that that's gonna take all the load
off the monolith and our concepts is
going to exist as a as a true micro
service and the cotton team is super
happy because now they're actually had
to run things on their own again that's
really sort of good developer experience
as well we are shrinking this model it
bit by bit so now we have service B that
might just be our web front-end so that
serves us a little of our sort of user
facing pages we've sort of brought that
across now again same process using our
load balancing and the API gateway we
can make that every sort of measured and
sort of careful change and now we're
able to Riley rely on communities in GK
specifically to do auto scaling of those
services now that we've sort of broken
them out right we can scale them
independently of each other
and independently of the monolith that
they rely on or were relying on we need
a little fancy we can start to use G RPC
obviously reduce the overheads only so
the traffic coming from our gateway back
to our services
reduced latency in many cases so we can
such a sort of iterative Li and
carefully bring in these it
sort of modernization efforts as well as
we break them all down but hey maybe
there are some services you do want to
keep on Prem there are services and as
others have discussed before regulatory
reasons maybe complexity reasons maybe
there are just truly a lot of
dependencies that are there you know
maybe there's specific hardware
requirements that yeah you know we can't
sort of get in the cloud maybe just
today or existing investments you want
to sit over leverage like you know what
I'm gonna break out subsea but I'm gonna
run out on pram and you know gko and
Primus part of anthos keep that there
but hey how does it talk to the other
micro services how does it discover
those things so what we can start to
build in is using setup our envoy
proxies this is the first step towards
our service mesh so in many ways like if
you know I've been familiar with sort of
envoy before the way you normally set it
up is in a container system you said
it's a sidecar
so all traffic coming into that sort of
container all those containers as pods
and communities it intercepts that is
effectively a front sort of a reverse
and front proxy for all traffic coming
into that application you can do sort of
canary through that you can have
multiple versions set up and you can do
some stuff like MPLS some mutual TLS as
well insecure and authenticate traffic
going between these services so that
service B&C can talk to each other would
be should not talk to say a if we had
our envoy there as well such builds a
little more so what we might have is we
have a control point so that's the
service MSC P that you can see here we
need something to orchestrate our
proxies right maybe initially they had a
fairly static config that we just built
into a config map and we deployed it
sort of you know as needed we didn't
make a lot of changes but we're
realizing hey operators need to be able
to sort of roll this out again carefully
they want to be able to make changes
dynamically without actually reader
forming the application that can
obviously be very easy sometimes in
communities but if it's a very stateful
application blood of dependencies it's
something you sort of want to take care
of and you might have a control point on
Chrome as well for managing the on voice
there so you have these sort of -
divorced control planes that do a lot of
the same thing and you caught me see
where I'm sort of going with us and what
we said is you get to is what we call it
a traffic director
so today traffic director works
through GCP directly and we're building
this out to sort of have a hybrid
approach as well so you can have a
control plane on gcpd managing all of
the service mesh on communities you can
have it manage the service measures in
other clusters be they on pram be they
are not the sort of cloud providers as
well that's really so that the dream are
going to get to so you have this like
unified control plane that you
developers interact with and wherever
those clusters are living and I
definitely recommend having definitely
more than one cluster four blast radius
you can manage all those set up as if
they're one large unit and making sure
that applications on say you know
platform cluster a doing say you're like
Jupiter notebook management something
like that or some data science jobs can
talk to the cluster running maybe some
batch training jobs as well so you want
to sort of have that cross cluster
communication but with a sort of
centralized control plane as well and
you know this is a hybrid approach here
so having this sort of singular control
plane as much as possible either
abstracts the need to write a control
plane on Prem or controls the on Prem
control plane so that you know maybe in
a worst-case scenario if there was a
connectivity issue between sort of on
Prem and reaching out to cloud you have
a local control plane that's can
continue to operate for as long as it
needs to when it's on so as a bit of a
recap you can see we've set up is this
monolith then we've started to break it
down piece by piece
so we've taken we're taking this really
carefully we build a load balancer and a
gateway as a preparation and a
foundation for how you want to do this
and that gives us again really useful
capabilities or Canarian traffic for
splitting traffic out but doing traffic
on you know IPs and lease connections
instead of based on actually the load of
my backends as well I can obviously keep
going down that path with my gateway
I've been have implemented BC to reduce
overheads and increases security on say
connection to other services that
support that as well so they made those
changes carefully service AHGG RPC
I build G RPC into service B I don't
again all the ocean do it all at once
and then I've broken out the one who
live sort of finally as a you know will
say service see here but there could be
services cdef on Prem and I've had this
sort of universal service specially
have talks to all applications and
manages the proxies managers those
sidecars for me as much as possible
because again what we are sort of
getting to here is we don't want to be
running all this infrastructure that's
sort of like in many cases adjacent to
the business goals we want to get to
right like most of you here manage the
end and now we have the cloud of chips
trucks a lot of that mostly and we have
communities but communities has a large
number of API is right in if you want to
start configuring say envoy you know go
I'd look at envoy proxy have a look at
the B config have a look at how you
could have managed that and you can
imagine a fleet of those you get its
config trip so control planes like SDR
control planes that sort of live like
traffic director I sort of I protract
the need to sort of have to do to lose
hands on management and you can keep
everything a little bit more centralized
particularly from a security or ops team
perspective so takeaways containerize
first definitely recommends that
recognize I recommend that so that it be
again migrant das has a great first
start and maybe if you have some Windows
apps or things like that that can't sort
of fit into that today you know there's
a processes maybe iteratively break that
out yourself D rescue migrations by
breaking them out piecemeal and having a
plan for each sort of piece right having
a plan that involves the network so you
can sort of make those changes quickly
again roll back those changes and and
critically monitor error rates trace
with traffic's going trace the
performance of your sort of newly
containerized and broken out
applications and leveraged service
measures to bridge on-prem with the
cloud if you're going to be keeping your
on-prem infrastructure or I have a multi
cloud environment as well you want to be
leveraging service measures to make sure
that these things can communicate where
they should communicate where they don't
communicate where they should so you
don't want like a PCI environment for
example communicating with non PCI
environment that's a horrible ordered
scope
having using a service measure to
prevent that at the networking layer can
make them really easy right you can have
fire rules you can have seviche mask
constraints you can have em TLS
constraints and layer those on to get
that sort of multiple layers of
protection
you